vamos a ver si podemos averiguar cuánto
es 256 256 esto elevado a la 4 séptimos
a la 4 séptimos entre entre 2 elevado
también a la cuatro séptimos y como
siempre te encargo que pausa el vídeo y
veas si puedes averiguar cuál es el
resultado ok vamos a trabajar estos
juntos y lo primero que quiero que veas
es que puedes encontrar esto un poco
intimidante sobre todo cuando ves algo
como 2 elevado a 4 séptimos y piensas
que esto no va a ser un número entero
entonces cómo podemos resolverlo
especialmente si no tenemos calculadora
am y bueno claro lo queremos resolver
sin ella pero la clave de esto es usar
las propiedades de los exponentes para
ver si podemos simplificar un poco esta
expresión y ver si podemos llegar a algo
un poco más sencillo y la primera
propiedad que debe de brincar te
inmediatamente
la siguiente si tengo x elevado a la
potencia a / he elevado la potencia
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que x / y
todo esto elevado a su vez a la potencia
a es decir que en esta situación
bueno pues ahora voy a tener lo
siguiente esto es exactamente lo mismo
que en este caso x es 256 y en este caso
bien es 2 por lo tanto me va a quedar lo
siguiente me va a quedar 256 esto
dividido entre 2 y todo esto elevado a
su vez a la potencia 4 séptimos estás de
acuerdo y bueno esto es mucho más
sencillo porque nosotros sabemos cuánto
es 256 entre 2 256 entre 2 es lo mismo
que 128 128 esto elevado a la potencia 4
séptimos ahora bien estoy seguro que
estás pensando que esto de aquí todavía
se ve un poco complicado como elevamos
128 a una potencia racional pero lo
importante aquí es que recuerdes que
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 128
esto elevado a la potencia un séptimo y
después esto elevado a la cuarta
potencia o bueno puede ser lo mismo que
no sé 128 esto elevado a la potencia
cuarta y después esto a su vez elevado a
la potencia un séptimo pero en este caso
se ve un poco complicado porque como vas
a obtener 128 elevado a la potencia 4 es
decir multiplicar 128 por sí mismo 4
veces parece ser una multiplicación muy
grande y vas a tener que trabajar con
números muy extensos y después a eso
sacar la raíz de séptima estoy seguro
que eso se ve muy
y por lo tanto no creo que quieras ir en
esa dirección así que mejor vamos a
reducir este número que tenemos aquí 128
elevado a la potencia o séptimo y
después lo vamos a elevar a la cuarta
potencia y bueno cuando tú ves esto
probablemente lo que te preguntes es si
no vamos a usar calculadora entonces
suena razonable que este valor sea un
número que podamos obtener por nuestra
cuenta y después de pensarlo un rato
puedes reconocer al 128 como una
potencia de 2 y tal vez 2 elevado a 7
sea 128 así que vamos a verificarlo si
nos tomamos las potencias de 2 bueno
primero tenemos al 22 la primera
potencia es 24
8 16
32 64 128 estás de acuerdo es decir que
dos por dos es cuatro por 12 8 por 12 16
por 12 32 por 12 64 por 2 128 así que 2
elevado a la séptima potencia es lo
mismo que 128 o inclusive lo podemos ver
así 128 elevado a la potencia un séptimo
esto es lo mismo que 2 o inclusive esto
lo podemos ver de la siguiente manera
como la raíz séptima de 128 esto es lo
mismo que dos así que ya está ahora
podemos simplificar todo esto todo esto
y decir que esto es lo mismo que dos de
lujo ahora tenemos que toda esta
expresión va a ser igual a 2 elevado a
la cuarta potencia y sabemos que todos
elevada a la cuarta potencia es lo mismo
que 16
esto es lo mismo que dos por dos por dos
por dos
esto es el valor de 16 y ya está esta
expresión loca y complicada con la que
empezamos no está de resultado
simplemente 16 se simplifica a 16